das ist die straße die ins feuer führt
die straße die samsung sie darauf jeden
tag hinaus fährt er nimmt uns mit in das
entfernung von jakutien eigentlich ist
der lehrer für handwerkskunst in diesen
tagen aber ist er feuerwehrmann
jakutien steht in flammen und wir sind
mit samson mittendrin sowie rund 4000
soldaten und freiwillige helfer viel zu
wenige in russlands weiter bildnis
wir brechen in jakutsk auf 5000
kilometer östlich von moskau von der
hauptstadt der republik sacha jakutien
offiziell heißt fahren wir gen westen
acht stunden lang
immer dem rauch entgegen
da vorne ist eine siedlung das feuer war
anfangs weit weg 50 60 kilometer jetzt
ist es schon auf bis zu zehn kilometer
ran gerückt oder auch 5 woran liegt das
denn am wind der wind treibt die flammen
unsere gruppe fühlt sich sicher bei
samsung das ist nicht sein erster
waldbrand das wird uns schnell klar aber
es ist sein bislang größter rings um uns
herum feuer die tiger brennt jakutien
sticker sumpfige wald steht lichterloh
in flammen
zwischenstopp in dieser situation hilft
jeder jedem samson checkt woher die
anderen männer kommen und ob sie hilfe
brauchen
ich dachte erst dass das feuerwehrleute
die kommen aus dabei einem ort in der
nähe aber das sind einfach nur anwohner
sie haben gesagt dass bei ihnen alles
bis zum schluss niedergebrannt ist da
sind ferienhäuser abgebrannt jagdhütten
und der ganze wald da gab es auch einen
pferdehof aber habt ihr noch steht ist
nicht sicher
samsung sagt wir sollten weiter fahren
sollten nach dem hof sehen also machen
wir uns auf den weg
3,4 millionen hektar eine fläche so groß
wie baden-württemberg steht in flammen
seit jahren ist das eine der schlimmsten
brand sommer die jakutien erlebt aus
moskau kommt wenig hilfe ein gesetz
erlaubt es brände in unbewohntem gebiet
einfach brennen zu lassen
die flammen fressen sich schon seit
monaten durch die wälder über dörfern
und den wenigen städten hängen dicke
schwere rauchschwaden sie reichen
inzwischen bis zum nordpol auch in
diesem dorf das auf unserem weg liegt
fällt das atmen schwer die augen tränen
gekickt wird trotzdem die menschen hier
sind all das gewohnt die gelassenheit
die wir erleben fast schon so rea
russland treffen wir in seiner werkstatt
er schraubt an seinem bus
ich lebe seit meiner geburt hier seit 42
jahren
können sie sich an frühere brender
erinnern weil ja es gab immer brände
aber niemals waren sie so heftig jedes
jahr brennt es aber so was erlebe ich
zum ersten mal
wir fahren weiter hinein in die nächste
rauchwand
kann man schon ungefähr schätzen wie
groß die fläche ist die brennt nein
dafür ist es noch zu früh viel zu früh
und zwei kilometer am tag kann das feuer
zurücklegen die tiger ist ein gigantisch
großes ein sehr sensibles ökosystem
brände gibt es hier regelmäßig sie
sorgen für fruchtbaren boden aber
inzwischen sorgt der klimawandel für
verheerende feuer so warm war es sie im
juni noch nie böden und sträucher
trockener der permafrost taut das eis
meter dick unter dem erdboden wird
dünner und befeuert den klimawandel
feuer außer kontrolle
[Musik]
wir finden den pferdehof von dem die
männer aus dabei berichtet haben niemand
ist mehr hier alle geflohen die flammen
sind zu nahe
[Musik]
und dann das
unser bus bleibt im morast stecken
rechts und links von uns brände mit
muskelkraft kriegen wir den da nicht
raus
es gibt hier keine anlaufstelle nur ein
ferienhaus geist aber niemand wir müssen
weiter fahren
während samsung versucht den bus auf zu
bocken läuft benzin aus dem tank mein
kollege alex hat einen geistesblitz er
stoppt das leck mit einer fft zwei maske
samsung und alec in diesem moment
sicherlich die mit den besten nerven
früher gab es hier gar keine straßen
also sind wir immer auf solchen fahrten
gefahren wir werden das auto da schon
rauskriegen
reiner zufall dass ein zweiter bus
vorbei kommt dessen fahrer und aus dem
matsch befreit hier auf der fläche der
größe indiens leben gerade einmal eine
knappe million menschen und wir machen
eine zufallsbekanntschaft
alles gut gegangen aber die panne hat
viel zeit gekostet ist am song führt uns
weg von hier
auf ein freies feld auf dem auch andere
hilfskräfte campieren wir sind
eingekreist drei große brände 15 meter
hohe flammen sie kommen er selbst
samsung zeigt nerven nerven keine angst
ich habe angst warum haben sie keine
warum na ja es ist schon schlimm aber
wir werden nicht weglaufen
wir sind menschen hier steht die ganze
technik hier gibt es rettungskräfte und
leute vom katastrophenschutzministerium
von der forstverwaltung alles profis sie
geben dem feuer keine chance
wir glauben ihm samsung der seit jahren
gegen die flammen gekämpft und der wie
sie alle hier große demut im herzen
trägt demut gegenüber der natur
nach vier stunden hat das feuer eine
schneise gefressen wir können hier weg
samsung führt uns heraus er wird
wiederkommen morgen schon denn die
gefahr ist noch lange nicht gebannt